[Música]
sin darnos cuenta así como se escucha
sin darnos cuenta muchas veces nosotros
mismos somos los que impedimos el éxito
y porque impedimos el éxito porque nos
ponemos límites no debemos de ponernos
límites en la vida siempre hay que
alcanzar nuestros sueños el camino al
éxito puede ser largo puede estar lleno
de obstáculos y puede estar lleno de
hoyos sin embargo todos y cada uno de
nosotros podemos llegar a él
el éxito está lleno de muchas
adversidades es por eso que el día de
hoy quiero platicar acerca de cuatro
elementos esenciales para avanzar hacia
el éxito son cosas muy comunes cosas que
vemos en nuestro día a día y que en
ocasiones no nos damos cuenta de lo
importante que pueden ser
todos y cada uno de nosotros tenemos
metas en la vida tenemos objetivos
tenemos algún sueño que cumplieron que
lograr sin embargo para hacerlo se
requiere de muchísima perseverancia yo
recuerdo hace algunos años que tuve la
oportunidad de hacer una asociación
civil con un grupo de jóvenes en donde
teníamos un fin únicamente hacer el bien
por los demás cuando empezamos esta
asociación civil nos vimos con un sinfín
de adversidades nos topamos con pared
vimos muchos odios en el camino y
bastantes obstáculos básicamente al
principio nadie creía en nosotros nadie
nos apoyaba y nos cerraban todas y cada
una de las puertas yo recuerdo muy bien
que cuando iniciamos con esta asociación
civil tuve la oportunidad de platicar
con un grupo de amigos éramos
aproximadamente 12 amigos estábamos en
una mesa y yo les platicaba les decía
queremos hacer una asociación entre
muchos jóvenes queremos hacer una
asociación que ayude que hago un
beneficio
en cada una de las ciudades del estado
tengamos una representación juvenil tíos
me decían no va a ser posible no lo
hagas no vas a poder está muy peligroso
no vale la pena que arriesgues tu tiempo
en esto sin embargo yo recuerdo que
cuando salí de esta reunión salí más
motivado que nunca y salí más optimista
que nunca yo estaba seguro que íbamos a
cumplir con nuestro objetivo y con
nuestra meta también recuerdo muy bien
que nos cerraban las puertas y esto les
puedo decir que de manera literal nos
cerraban las puertas en una ocasión y
vamos a hacer una actividad cultural en
donde íbamos en una escuela a hacer un
concurso de canto ya teníamos todo listo
teníamos a los alumnos que estaban
participando teníamos a los maestros que
ya estaban de acuerdo al director y
llegamos a ese día en la mañana a la
escuela por supuesto bien motivados y
bien contentos porque íbamos a hacer
esta actividad y cuando llegamos ya
estaba el director esperándonos en la
y nos dijo discúlpenme pero aquí no van
a poder entrar en esta ocasión no van a
poder llevar a cabo su evento y nosotros
elegimos porque nos dijo ustedes con
esta asociación no van a entrar el día
de hoy y bueno así como nos cerraron esa
puerta nos cerraron muchísimas más pero
cuando nos cerraban una puerta nosotros
abríamos 100 200 300 y hasta 400 puertas
más éramos optimistas teníamos actitud
éramos perseverantes y sabíamos que
íbamos a lograr con nuestro objetivo a
pesar de las adversidades que podemos
vivir en nuestra vida que yo estoy
seguro que todos y cada uno de ustedes
tienen adversidades o han pasado por
alguna de ellas es importante que sepan
que con la perseverancia podemos lograr
grandes cosas
básicamente se requiere de mucha actitud
ser proactivo ser optimista a ser
persistente todo lo que tenga que ver
con actitud nos va a ayudar a que
cumplamos con nuestras metas y nuestros
objetivos yo recuerdo que tuvimos estas
adversidades pero logramos hacer una
asociación civil muy reconocida a nivel
estatal
por otra parte yo estoy seguro que todos
y cada uno de ustedes tienen fortalezas
todos nacemos con un talento nato todos
absolutamente todos nacemos con un
talento nato pero si ahorita yo les
preguntara para que son buenos
probablemente la mayoría me contestaría
para todo ok no sé muy pocas personas
tienen y saben cuáles son sus talentos
las personas que saben cuáles son sus
talentos son las personas que van
llegando al éxito de manera mucho más
rápido y es importante que detectemos
cuáles son nuestros talentos qué es lo
que podemos hacer qué es lo que sabemos
hacer y empezamos a utilizar
cuando estuvimos en esta asociación
civil yo pude lograr identificar un
talento que no tenía muy bien reconocido
y me acuerdo que era el de integrar
personas nosotros teníamos las ganas de
hacer un festival muy grande y en este
festival no necesitábamos de gente
talentosa de gente que supiera cantar de
gente que supiera del tema de
videojuegos de tecnologías y de todas
las cuestiones que le gustan la juventud
nosotros no teníamos dinero para poderlo
hacer no teníamos a alguien que nos
apoyara en ocasiones había gente que nos
daba la mano sin embargo este festival
era mucho más grande de lo que se había
hecho y pudimos de manera muy importante
integrar a personas que tenían distintos
talentos uno se dedicó al tema musical
otro se dedicó al tema tecnológico otro
se dedicó al tema deportivo en fin
pudimos lograr integrar talentos y con
esta integración de talentos pudimos
hacer un festival que no se había
logrado en el estado por supuesto que
los jóvenes estaban sumamente contentos
y esto a nosotros nos llenaba de mucha
satisfacción por otra parte el trabajar
en equipo es algo que sin duda nos ayuda
a lograr de manera mucho más rápida a
cumplir nuestras metas y nuestros
objetivos yo recuerdo también que en una
ocasión queríamos hacer una carrera de
colores muy grande nuestra meta era que
fueran 1200 personas pero no sabíamos
cómo se realizaban no sabíamos que
teníamos que hacer y no sabíamos por
dónde empezar lo que hicimos con esto
fue que integramos a una gran cantidad
de personas que tenían el interés y
trabajando en equipo pudimos lograr algo
muy grande unas personas se dedicaron al
punto de hidratación otras aventar los
colores otras estar en la meta otras a
dar las medallas y gracias a esto
logramos hacer que esta carrera fuera
sumamente exitosa participaron más de
1500 personas rompimos nuestro propio
récord pero no podíamos haberlo logrado
si no hubiéramos tenido este trabajo en
equipo que es sumamente importante
cuando queramos llegar al éxito
tenemos que encontrar cuáles son
nuestros talentos
y encontrando nuestros talentos va a ser
mucho más fácil que alcancemos nuestras
metas y nuestros objetivos como lo
comentamos tenemos que enfocarnos muy
bien en qué es lo que sabemos hacer y de
esta manera empezar a trabajar en ello
para poder desarrollar estos talentos se
requiere de un ingrediente muy
importante que es la preparación las
personas que tienen talento pueden
llegar a ser exitosos pero cuando se
preparan van a potencializar lo que
tienen dentro de ellos su talento y lo
que pueden realizar
todas y cada uno de ustedes tienen
conocimientos tienen experiencias y de
manera personal yo quiero decirles que
yo aprendo de todo lo que veo aprendo de
todo lo que escucho lo que estudio y
básicamente aprendo de cada una de las
cosas que veo en la vida es una
recomendación que sin duda les quisiera
dar y que les va a ayudar en la vida
para poder aprender de todas las
personas a las que conocen las personas
con las que conviven pero sobre todo que
puedan aprender de las personas que
tienen mucho más experiencia que
nosotros y que tienen grandes historias
como comentábamos a nosotros nos decían
que no teníamos suficiente experiencia y
que estábamos preparados y al final de
cuentas éramos jóvenes y nos decían los
jóvenes no saben lo que hacen no tienen
la experiencia pero yo puedo decirles
que es todo lo contrario yo me di cuenta
que los jóvenes estaban más preparados
que nunca yo me di cuenta que los
jóvenes tenían más ganas que nunca y que
los jóvenes estaban listos para lo que
viniera y recuerdo también muy bien que
el tema de la preparación me ayudó a
poder desarrollar esta asociación civil
yo estudio una maestría en gestión
pública aplicada y cuando estudie esta
maestría llevé una materia que se
llamaba organizaciones no
gubernamentales en donde básicamente nos
enseñaban todo para hacer asociaciones
civiles acabé la maestría pasó un tiempo
y yo me quedé con la idea de que quería
desarrollar algo grande una asociación
algo que nos ayudará a hacer el bien
común y cuando se presentó la
oportunidad gracias a que yo tenía esa
preparación gracias a que yo tenía esos
conocimientos la puede desarrollar de
manera exitosa y pudimos integrar un
grupo muy grande el cual hizo el
beneficio a todos los demás por otra
parte también recuerdo que en una
ocasión íbamos a hacer una campaña de
donación y básicamente teníamos todo
listo ya teníamos el salón ya teníamos
el mobiliario ya teníamos el audio
teníamos todo lo que se requería para
hacer esta campaña sin embargo nos
faltaba una cosa muy importante la gente
experta para poderle sacar la sangre a
los pacientes
y recuerdo que fuimos a tocar las
puertas a un hospital y llegamos con la
persona encargada del área de donaciones
elegimos por favor ayúdanos queremos
hacer esta campaña que es hecha por
jóvenes hacia la sociedad en donde la
intención es que consigamos una gran
cantidad de donadores y como siempre nos
cerraron las puertas nos dijeron con
nosotros no cuenten pero bueno seguimos
adelante y fuimos a otro hospital nos
encontramos con una doctora que fue
sumamente amable que nos abrió las
puertas y dijo por supuesto que cuentan
conmigo y con todo mi equipo de trabajo
y pudimos realizar esta campaña en donde
participaron más de 200 personas y bueno
esta sangre que se donó fue beneficio
para muchas personas del estado a lo que
voy con esto es que si no hubiéramos
tenido a una persona experta una persona
preparada a una persona que supiera
acerca del tema nosotros por más ganas
que hubiéramos tenido no hubiéramos
alcanzado realizar esto que fue tan
importante
pues bueno como lo hemos comentado se
puede tener talento pero sin
conocimiento y sin experiencia nos vamos
a quedar muy limitados en el camino es
por eso que la preparación es otro los
elementos importantes para alcanzar el
éxito
los valores juegan un papel fundamental
para la sociedad juegan un papel
fundamental para todos los valores
básicamente ayudan a que la sociedad y
las personas puedan funcionar de manera
adecuada lamentablemente ahora nos hemos
encontrado con muchas personas que
carecen de valores se puede decir
los valores pues ya no aplican para
muchas personas ahora y la verdad que es
lamentable porque eso es lo que mueve
que las cosas se dan mueve a muchas
personas para que en realidad puedan
pasar cosas maravillosas y recuerdo que
cuando estuvimos integrando este grupo
de jóvenes a nivel estatal puede
constatar que existen tres valores
sumamente importantes el compromiso la
responsabilidad y el respeto yo recuerdo
que viajaba de ciudad en ciudad y
decíamos juntas con diferentes jóvenes
en donde platicaba con ellos veíamos
cuáles eran sus ideas pero sobre todo
las desarrollamos y les poníamos ya una
fecha para que ellos la cumplieran
cuando nosotros hacíamos esto los
jóvenes estaban más comprometidos que
nunca porque ellos estaban desarrollando
su proyecto ellos sabían que lo iban a
lograr y tenían una idea que durante
años no habían podido hacer cuando
nosotros les damos la oportunidad cuando
les presentábamos la plataforma los
jóvenes se comprometían pero aparte eran
sumamente responsables
lograr cumplir con sus objetivos y eso
sin duda nos ayudó también a llegar al
éxito pero el respeto como todos lo
sabemos es fundamental si tú respetas a
una persona esa persona te va a respetar
de regreso y cuando eso pasa pues bueno
cosas extraordinarias suceden es por eso
que los valores son fundamentales en el
camino hacia el éxito yo les diría a
todos que apliquemos los valores que los
valores juegan una parte muy importante
y que si en los valores nos vamos a
quedar muy limitados también en el
camino hacia el éxito pues bueno
alcanzar el éxito que requiere pues
requiere de una metodología requiere de
lo que hemos venido platicando de algo
que he podido formular en mi vida a
través de experiencias a través de
conocimientos en los demás a través de
las personas con las que me he podido
rodear yo les podría decir que
básicamente el éxito equivale a la
actitud más el talento más la
preparación más los valores cuando
sumamos todo esto hacemos que cosas
grandes sucedan
yo les quiero decir que cuando tengan un
proyecto en mente le metan todas las
ganas le meten mucha actitud sean
proactivos sean optimistas son
perseverantes sean persistentes la
actitud juega un papel fundamental en
esto también cuando sepan cuáles son sus
talentos empiecen a desarrollarlos pero
aparte de eso prepárense para que se
potencialicen y que sean personas que
con esa preparación lleguen sumamente
lejos también quiero comentarles que los
valores son nuestra guía en la vida las
personas que tienen valores son las
personas que van avanzando que van
creciendo yo estoy seguro que a todos y
cada uno de ustedes les ha tocado ver a
personas que son groseras personas que
se portan mal personas que nos faltan al
respeto y cuando esto sucede nosotros
pintamos una raya es por eso que el
respeto juega un papel fundamental para
cada uno de nosotros pero sobre todo
para poder llegar al éxito
y bueno como lo comentamos quiero que
sepan que el único límite para alcanzar
el éxito el único límite somos nosotros
mismos tenemos todas las herramientas en
nuestras manos tenemos todo para ser
exitosos busquemos un sueño y cumplamos
lo yo soy muy marrón y este fue mi
plática tec
[Aplausos]
[Música]